[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en que
hacemos un resumen de las noticias más
destacadas relacionadas con la pandemia
del cob y 19 en nuestro continente a
continuación algunos de los temas que
vamos a tratar en este episodio
noticias destacadas a nivel
internacional fue la aprobación por
parte de la fed el ente regulador de
medicamentos y alimentos en eeuu a la
vacuna desarrollada por la farmacéutica
pfiezer by ontex se trata de la primera
vacuna a nivel internacional en recibir
esta aprobación anteriormente tenía
solamente aprobación para uso de
emergencia
hablaremos también del alcance que tiene
esta medida para la vacunación a nivel
internacional con solamente el 60% de la
población cifras al cierre de hoy
con vacunas ya completas eeuu está
siendo fuertemente golpeado por la ola
de contagios de la variante delta está
dejando casi 100.000 casos nuevos por
día el gobierno ha intentado fomentar la
inmunización sin mayor éxito un poco más
de mano dura si han tenido algunas de
las empresas que han obligado a algunos
de sus trabajadores a vacunarse veremos
en detalle también cuál es la situación
en florida epicentro de la pandemia en
estados unidos y también destacado en el
programa daremos un vistazo a los
territorios franceses
aquí en nuestro continente
algunos de ellos aparentemente están
bajo control pero la situación es
particularmente difícil en guadalupe y
en martinica
en esta última el número de casos llevó
a tener que prolongar el confinamiento y
a retomar las aulas virtuales daremos
una mirada a las cifras para ver cómo
está la situación en esos territorios
pues vamos a comenzar el programa
comencemos con cifras balance de cómo
terminamos la semana en cuanto a
contagios y a personas fallecidas en
diferentes países de la región vamos a
comenzar en centroamérica guatemala
tiene más de 455 mil casos y más de
11.600 personas han fallecido en el
vecino el salvador el pulgarcito de
américa los casos superan ya los 94 mil
y los fallecidos llegan a los 2 mil 800
costa rica ya contabiliza más de 452 mil
900 casos y unos 5 mil 400 casos de
personas fallecidas nos vamos ahora
hasta la zona andina en suramérica
ecuador superó los 500 mil casos y más
de 32 mil personas han fallecido pero
tiene 2.1 millones de casos y 198 mil
personas han perdido la vida a lo largo
de toda esta emergencia sanitaria y ya
están próximos a llegar a la cifra de
los 200.000 y vamos a finalizar con
bolivia en donde hay más de 400.000
casos y más de 18.300 personas han
fallecido
vamos a ver puntualmente el caso de eeuu
veamos allí siguen aumentando los casos
cada día son más los hospitales
saturados y también menos las camas
disponibles en las uci así es como están
las cosas veamos algunas cifras eeuu
contabiliza para el cierre de esta
semana 38 millones 422 mil 999 casos los
fallecidos ya llegan a los 633 mil
ochocientos en ese país han sido
inoculadas más de
364 millones de dosis de vacunas
solamente entre el 51 y el 60 por ciento
de la población ha sido vacunada con el
esquema completo
59.19 por ciento según las cifras
exactas
y a pesar de la disponibilidad de las
vacunas y la aprobación de estas ya para
ser usadas en eeuu el estado de florida
es ahora el foco de la pandemia en la
unión americana hay hospitales saturados
hay muchos casos nuevos por día allí en
la florida y con alto nivel si en la
ciudad de miami vamos a conversar para
conocer más detalles de lo que está
sucediendo allí anthony comencemos por
el problema que más preocupa y es la
alta demanda de camas uci y los
hospitales saturados en el sur de
florida cómo está la situación
pues sí hola que tal a santiago pues
como bien apuntaba la situación de los
hospitales en florida es muy preocupante
básicamente porque según han apuntado
varios directores de centros sanitarios
se están quedando sin camas disponibles
para atender a las personas que sufren
mayores complicaciones derivadas del
comité 19 según el departamento de salud
del estado unas 17.000 personas están
hospitalizadas con corona a virus y un
53 por ciento más de la mitad requieren
cuidados intensivos el escenario es
alarmante en el sur en miami donde hay
una mayor tasa de contagios y también de
personas en estado grave y también donde
sólo habría entre un 3 y un 6 por ciento
de las camas disponibles la mayoría
advierten los médicos son personas que
no han sido vacunadas y al mismo tiempo
el gobernador de florida que no ha
implementado ninguna medida anti kobe ha
estado abriendo sitios de tratamiento de
anticuerpos en el estado ron de sant y
es dijo que espera que los próximos días
se abran hasta 21 sitios de tratamiento
en todo florida un tratamiento que
obviamente ha sido aprobado por la afe
de la administración
y medicamentos de eeuu antonio y le hago
la pregunta del millón que es lo que ha
provocado que florida se haya convertido
en el estado foco de la pandemia en este
momento puede ser la llegada masiva de
los turistas que no hay casi
restricciones por parte de las
autoridades o también un tema de
autocuidado que la gente no respetan las
normas
pues la razón principal es que la
variante delta que ya se ha demostrado
que es muy contagiosa está afectando
especialmente a la población más joven
también a los niños la razón como
decíamos antes es que muchos de ellos se
muestran reacios a la vacuna y aún no se
han puesto la dosis además también
porque el gobernador ya ha impulsado
varias órdenes ejecutivas para que las
administraciones públicas y también las
empresas privadas no puedan implementar
ningún tipo de regulación para evitar
que las personas que no están vacunadas
puedan acceder a ciertos servicios como
ir al cine oa un restaurante la última
polémica aquí en florida fue la medida
del gobernador de santis que prohibió
los mandatos de mascarillas en las
escuelas pero varios distritos escolares
entre ellos miami han desafiado la orden
y ahora requieren el tapabocas a los
niños los condados que ahora requieren
ese cubrebocas recuerdan que los niños
menores de 12 años aún no tienen acceso
a la vacuna porque no ha sido aprobada y
porque se está viendo también un
incremento de casos positivos y graves
en ellos el gobernador ha amenazado
incluso con retirar los fondos a quienes
no cumplan con sus directrices una
decisión que ya ha terminado en los
tribunales y que obviamente va a ir para
largo
antonio ahora que la vacuna de facer fue
aprobada por la fd a allí en la unión
americana se espera que haya un impulso
de la vacunación allí por parte de las
autoridades o que haya otro tipo de
restricciones para poder mitigar el
impacto que está teniendo la variante
del está allí en el estado de florida
que dicen
parece que al menos aquí en florida el
gobernador no va a tomar ninguna medida
especial para promover la vacunación
especialmente en aquellos grupos de
población que se muestran contrarios a
vacunarse recordemos que casi la mitad
de todos los residentes del estado aún
no se han vacunado y eso es algo que
preocupa a los sanitarios que ven como
la tasa de contagios sigue aumentando y
como los hospitales siguen llenándose de
pacientes graves las administraciones
locales prácticamente no tienen margen
de maniobra para poder incentivar la
inoculación entre la población y algunos
organismos públicos están pidiendo a sus
empleados vacunarse y quienes no quieran
hacerlo pues deberán someterse a pruebas
periódicas de coronavirus un hospital de
miami incluso obligará a asistir a un
curso diario de coronavirus a los que no
se hallan inoculado así que parece que
la situación va a ser bastante difícil
aquí en florida santiago antonio muchas
gracias por estar el reporte preocupante
lo que sucede allí en el estado de
florida la noticia de la semana la dio
la fd a la administración federal de
medicamentos y alimentos el uso de la
vacuna desarrollada por las
farmacéuticas pfizer y variante que
dicha vacuna ya tenía luz verde pero
solamente para su uso de emergencia
ahora con su aprobación total para todo
este país se espera que aquellos
escépticos que aún no se han inmunizado
lo hagan y más cuando la variante delta
está avanzando rápidamente
un anuncio que busca cambiar la opinión
de muchos escépticos la administración
de alimentos y medicamentos de eeuu
aprueba totalmente la vacuna de fisher y
bryant contra el coi 19
si bien esta y otras vacunas han
cumplido con los rigurosos estándares
científicos de la fda para la
autorización del uso de emergencia como
la primera vacuna kobe 19 aprobada por
la rda
el público puede estar seguro de que
esta vacuna cumple con los estándares
máximos de la fd en cuanto a seguridad
eficacia y calidad de fabricación que
requerimos para un producto aprobado
en diciembre el regulador de
medicamentos estadounidense permitió su
uso de emergencia para inocular a
personas de 16 años en adelante más
tarde en mayo la autorizó para menores a
partir de los 12 años más de 204
millones de personas han recibido esta
vacuna en eeuu sin embargo alrededor de
85 millones de estadounidenses que son
elegibles para vacunarse son escépticos
y no lo han hecho sólo en mis sedes
rawlings blake
permítanme decir esto en voz alta y
clara si usted es uno de los millones de
estadounidenses que dijeron que no
recibirían la inyección hasta que no
cuenten con la aprobación total y final
de la fed ahora esto acaba de suceder
llegó el momento que ha estado esperando
es hora de vacunarse por ser tan firme
que racing un poco después del anuncio
de la sda el pentã gono exigirá que 1,3
millones de militares estén obligados a
vacunarse el alcalde de nueva york
también dijo que emitirá una orden para
exigir que los 148.000 maestros y
personal de escuelas públicas de la
ciudad reciban al menos una dosis de la
vacuna antes del 27 de septiembre
después del inicio de clases lo mismo
sucederá con el personal escolar en
chicago los ángeles y washington las
autoridades esperan que la aprobación
impulso de un aumento en la tasa de
inmunización en todo el país en medio
del aumento en los contagios debido a la
variante delta
ya lo veíamos desde washington el
presidente joe biden ha insistido en la
vacunación para contrarrestar la
situación en diferentes áreas del país
principalmente en florida algunas
empresas también han tomado medidas como
obligar a sus trabajadores a inmunizarse
vamos a conversar sobre estos aspectos
con cristóbal vázquez corresponsal de
france 24 esta vez desde la ciudad de
chicago en el estado de illinois en
cristóbal destacamos la aprobación de la
fda por parte de la feria de esta vacuna
de la farmacéutica pfiezer y variante
que reacciones ha habido en torno a esto
por parte de las autoridades de los
partidos políticos de los mismos
ciudadanos frente a este tema
la aprobación de la vacuna por parte de
la administración de alimentos y drogas
de eeuu es el estándar de oro que según
el presidente yo bailé debería motivar a
cerca del 40 por ciento de adultos
estadounidenses que siguen sin vacunarse
una reciente encuesta de la fundación
kaiser encontró que 3 de cada 10 adultos
no vacunados dicen estar motivados a
ponerse la vacuna ahora que fue aprobada
completamente por la fd a al respecto
hospitales y especialistas de salud en
eeuu están anticipando que muchos
adultos querrán ponerse una tercera
dosis de forma no ordenada y que muchos
papás buscarán desesperadamente también
vacunar a sus hijos menores de 12 años
edad mínima para la que fue aprobada
esta vacuna en mayo del próximo año
cristóbal a raíz de la aprobación de
esta vacuna y en eeuu tal parece que el
gobierno se está apalancando en esta
medida para impulsar el plan de
vacunación y tal parece que lo están
usando como un mecanismo para convencer
a los que no estaban convencidos del
todo del uso de las vacunas que dicen
sobre este tema
y vaivén fue enfático y dijo que si los
empresarios líderes de las ongs o
políticos locales o estatales estaban
esperando por la aprobación completa
para exigir la vacuna en sus
organizaciones pues le pides les pidió
entonces que lo hicieran ya le exigieran
como él lo hizo en su momento hace un
mes de hecho a los trabajadores
federales afirmó que lo que de lo
contrario pues tenían estos trabajadores
que pues enfrentarse a requisitos
estrictos como el porte de máscaras en
cualquier espacio cerrado entre otros su
llamado fue sobre todo a las empresas
privadas a que lo exijan antes de
regresar a la normalidad en sus
edificios cabe mencionar que facer es la
primera vacuna en recibir la aprobación
completa de la administración de
alimentos y drogas y los reguladores
pues todavía están revisando la
aplicación de modernas y de johnson y
johnson que podrían pues estar listas
estas decisiones en cerca de un mes
sobre si se ponen completamente estas
vacunas tienen la aprobación completa de
la
cristóbal otro anuncio destacado de la
semana lo veíamos en el reportaje es ese
pedido del presidente byte en de llevar
a la vacunación a 1.3 millones de
integrantes de las fuerzas armadas y
también el anuncio de delta airlines de
descontarle 200 dólares del salario a
sus empleados por cada mes que estén sin
vacunarse que dicen sobre esta
controvertida medida
el pentágono anunció que los 14 millones
de soldados en servicio activo en eeuu
tendrán que ser vacunados tras la
aprobación completa de la vacuna el
departamento de defensa ordenó al
ejército comenzar el proceso de
inmediato pero no estableció un
cronograma específico según datos del
pentágono alrededor del 68% de los
soldados activos están completamente
vacunados la aerolínea delta por su
parte les empezará a cobrar a sus
empleados que están registrados en su
plan de salud en el plan de salud de la
empresa a 200 dólares más de sobrecargo
mensual por no estar vacunados además se
exigirá a partir de septiembre que los
que no se quieran vacunar tengan que
portar la máscara y hacerse la prueba
cada semana hay que mencionar que pues
otras aerolíneas como air canada también
están exigiendo la vacuna a sus
empleados
gracias cristóbal por este reporte desde
la ciudad de chicago en el estado de
illinois sobre lo que está sucediendo
allí en eeuu en torno a diferentes temas
relacionados con la pandemia de kobe 19
vamos ahora a ver cómo está avanzando la
vacunación en américa latina' les
presentamos el porcentaje de las
personas que ya han recibido el esquema
completo de vacunación en nuestra región
es decir dos dosis o uno dependiendo de
la vacuna comenzamos con uruguay allí el
setenta y 1.33 por ciento de los
habitantes ya recibieron el esquema
completo de vacunación en canadá el 65
punto 92 por ciento en el salvador el 38
punto 13 por ciento pasamos a colombia
en donde el 28 punto 0 7 por ciento de
la población ya está completamente
vacunado finalizamos con brasil que
alcanza el 27 punto 33 por ciento
y en el marco de un estudio clínico fue
realizado que fue realizado en chile en
un concierto para evaluar el impacto que
este tipo de eventos tiene en relación
con la propagación de coronavirus tras
este evento se le va a dar un
seguimiento muy especial a cada uno de
los participantes para determinar los
protocolos adecuados que ayuden a
retomar las actividades de
entretenimiento y de la industria
musical en ese país suramericano veamos
la música ensaya es el nombre del primer
gran concierto realizado en chile desde
el inicio de la pandemia de kobe 19
organizado por la sociedad chilena de
autores intérpretes musicales y la
universidad de chile
pero tiene otra particularidad
hace parte de un ensayo clínico que
busca medir el impacto de los conciertos
en la propagación del coronavirus 200
voluntarios asistieron al recital del
grupo chancho en piedra
es muy emocionante espero mucho tiempo
poder poner música en vivo
y de verdad
la sala fue equipada de inhibidores de
co2 sistemas de ventilación y un
estricto protocolo sanitario para los
asistentes que debían portar mascarillas
dar pruebas de vacunación y mostrar
resultados recientes de pruebas de cr
una esperanza de la apertura para un
sector fuertemente golpeado por la
pandemia
el estudio de este ensayo clínico
inédito en latinoamérica va a sentar los
precedentes para que pueda volver la
música a los escenarios también la arte
escénica una semana después del
concierto los asistentes se someterán a
nuevas pruebas pcr esperamos los
resultados nos permitan avanzar a un
segundo evento con un mayor aforo y de
posteriormente un tercer evento que será
el definitivo y final y con esos
resultados nosotros vamos a ir al
ministerio de salud 16 millones de
personas se han infectado con kobe 19 en
chile y más de 45 mil fallecieron según
el ministerio de salud pero pese a todo
el país tuvo una exitosa campaña de
inoculación con más de 80 por ciento de
la población con un esquema de
vacunación completo
y avanza en nuestra región la vacunación
en menores de edad personas de entre los
12 y los 17 años que pueden acceder a
una vacuna de adn mensajero para
protegerse de el coronavirus veamos cómo
están las cosas 11 países ya están
vacunando a los menores de edad el
salvador colombia paraguay chile
argentina solamente por mencionar
algunos de la lista otros ya aprobaron
la vacunación para este segmento de la
sociedad pero van a comenzar en las
próximas semanas se espera que lo hagan
ahora en septiembre mexico cuba y brasil
los estaremos reportando por supuesto en
unos días aquí en kobe 19 la semana en
américa
y damos inicio a la consulta con el
doctor carlos eduardo pérez médico
infectólogo y asesor científico de
france 24 de doctor pérez bienvenido
como siempre es un gusto conversar con
usted de diferentes temas que tenemos
aquí en la agenda y comienzo por
preguntarle por el tema de la semana que
es el aval de la vacuna de facer por
parte de las autoridades de eeuu que
esto en la práctica que significa que ya
haya recibido la aprobación por parte de
las autoridades porque si bien la
estamos usando normalmente con una
autorización de emergencia si la
diferencia de la full aprobación
significa que ya pasa ya el conocimiento
que se adquiere la vacuna es suficiente
para poder recomendar hoy y ahora en
adelante y que ya los estudios que se
llaman de fármaco y las extendidas es
decir de esa vigilancia que se hace en
todas las pruebas vacunados han sido
exitosas y permite que esta aprobación
permita su uso no solamente ahora
durante la emergencia sino en un futuro
posiblemente
doctor pérez usted de haber visto el
debate que hay no solamente en redes
sociales sino también entre los colegas
entre amigos entre personas sobre el uso
de una doble mascarilla porque
aparentemente esto prevendría
contagiarse de la variante delta que
como ya sabemos es mucho más contagiosa
que dicen sobre este tema la comunidad
científica esto verdaderamente puede
funcionar o esto es contraproducente
para nosotros tener doble mascarilla
hay que valorar las situaciones en las
que estemos enfrentados es muy probable
que la mascarilla convencional en un
espacio libre al aire libre no tenga
mayor significancia cuando unas
mascarillas probablemente el escenario
donde se tengan que usar la mascarilla
por lo menos de tipo quirúrgico es en
los ambientes que son cerrados ambientes
como aulas escolares por ejemplo centros
de recreación algún tipo de restaurantes
en esos sitios debería procurarse porque
sean
por ejemplo en oficinas de gobierno el
uso de la mascarilla quirúrgica utilizar
una doble mascarilla y que incluso puede
ser de tela para traer mayor pruebas de
protección por tienes una barrera
mecánica pero no sería para todos los
momentos sino para los momentos donde
haya mayor interacción humana es una
probabilidad hay que mirarlo con cautela
pero sí es recomendable tener
mascarillas de buena eficiencia en
ambientes cerrados cuando las
actividades al aire libre realmente no
es necesidad de utilizar doble
mascarilla importantes aclaraciones
doctores sobre este punto de la doble
mascarilla pasó a preguntarle ahora por
las consultas que hemos visto en
nuestras redes sociales lo hemos
conversado con usted y es la vacunación
en madres lactantes que dice la
comunidad de la comunidad científica en
que puede beneficiar esto al bebé al
recién nacido
esto ha sido una noticia muy importante
el primero hemos tenido la posibilidad
de que las mujeres embarazadas que se
vacunen es una una segura y que no pasa
al niño pero critican las mujeres
lactantes
producen anticuerpos es decir las
células que nos defienden las proteínas
que nos defienden y transmiten esos
anticuerpos a los bebés eso hace que ese
binomio madre-hijo sea protegido a
través de la vacuna sea en el momento
del embarazo o sea en el momento de la
lactancia y por eso el llamado a todas
las mujeres a que lleven a la vacunación
porque se protegen ellas ya lo más al
lado que la vida de sus hijos
doctor pérez lo conversamos en el
programa del debate donde usted fue uno
de los invitados en el panel de expertos
y le quería preguntar por la variante de
alta en américa latina' si estamos
haciendo lo suficiente para prevenir
tener que enfrentarnos a una ola de
contagio para final de año o en unas
pocas semanas y hago la pregunta porque
vemos el caso de méxico que en este
momento ha batido todos los récords por
cuenta de la variante de alta
sí yo creo que sí nítidamente hay dos
escenarios en la variante está lo que
previene su expansión es la vacunación
masiva
rápida y con y lo segundo es la
disciplina social lo que hemos visto es
que las coberturas vacunales en nuestra
región van a mediana marcha no quieren
que no se estén haciendo pero todavía
falta más para acelerar la vacunación
entre más inmunizados estemos menos
probabilidad de que haya un efecto de
esta delta que sea devastador y por otro
lado la conducta social durante este
tiempo debemos haber aprendido las
medidas de prevención la ventilación de
los espacios el mantener el alejamiento
físico y el correcto uso de la
mascarilla la vacuna sin mascarilla no
va a funcionar ante la variante deben
ser las dos entonces creo que en américa
latina nos falta la pedagogía para
mantener la prevención y acelerar los
procesos de vacunación todas son
insuficientes los esfuerzos y esperamos
que esto crezca para que la próxima
semana no venga esta variante o si viene
nos tengan lo estemos lo mejor
preparados para que no tenga el impacto
que estamos viendo en mail y vimos en
nuestros países de europa dr tenemos que
seguir entonces en pie de lucha contra
el coronavirus muchas gracias por estar
con nosotros en el programa de haber
aclarado todas estas dudas para nuestra
audiencia ya les decíamos en el programa
el debate de france 24 conversamos sobre
la amenaza de la variante delta en
américa latina y conversamos con anna
céspedes directora general de
operaciones de international aids
vaccine initiative sobre lo que
representa esta amenaza para nuestra
región y esto fue lo que nos comentó
sobre que debemos estar un paso adelante
del virus para poder enfrentarlo veamos
primero necesitamos vacunas eficaces no
todas tienen el mínimo el mismo nivel de
eficacia y necesitamos vacunas que
alcancen al mayor porcentaje posible de
la población eeuu está avanzando muy
lento muy lentamente estamos actualmente
estancados en el 52% europa está más
avanzada pero latinoamérica está por
debajo del 30% tenemos que subir esas
cifras eso es muy importante hay que
también prevenir la vacunación estamos
viendo que no solo que el virus muta
sino que además muta de una manera que
lo hace de alguna manera menos que las
vacunas sean menos resistentes es decir
las vacunas siguen protegiendo los de la
enfermedad grave pero no nos protegen de
la infección y esto es muy importante
porque eso significa que personas
vacunadas tienen que seguir llevando
mascarilla la vacuna es una herramienta
una herramienta indispensable pero la
mascarilla también lo es y aunque es
incómodo es una herramienta muy eficaz
que nos puede permitir ir a trabajar
tener pequeñas reuniones y tener una
vida social que de alguna manera también
reactiva la economía por eso creo que es
importante destacar eso
y social junto con las vacunas nos va a
permitir ir ir manejando esta situación
de una manera que sea la nueva realidad
no volver a lo de antes pero una nueva
realidad que nos permita que economía y
salud vayan de la mano
era anna céspedes quien estuvo con
nosotros en el debate de france 24
hablando precisamente de lo que
representa la amenaza de la variante
delta para la región de américa latina'
bueno y esta semana también fue
conmemorado el día internacional del
dengue que es una enfermedad que sigue
presente en nuestra región cada año más
de 50 millones de personas son
infectadas con dengue con la aparición
del cob y 19 diagnosticarla es muy
difícil porque hay una similitud en
cuanto a los síntomas pero tal parece
que hay una solución para este problema
veamos
sigue la guerra contra el dengue en el
día internacional de la lucha contra
esta enfermedad mortal se recordó que el
virus transmitido por el mosquito aedes
agypti no se ha ido lo peor es que los
casos subieron estos últimos años y con
el coronavirus se complicaron los
diagnósticos antes la impresión es que
los casos de dengue se están diluyendo
en dentro del propio kobe porque muchas
veces la sintomatología es similar como
dolor en el cuerpo fiebre dolor de
cabeza en brasil se pronostica que entre
2022 y 2023 los casos de dengue aumenten
significativamente
para poder luchar contra la
proliferación del mosquito aedes agypti
hay prevenciones básicas pero desde hace
unos años se implementó en 11 países la
bacteria wolbachia entre colonias de
mosquitos que tiene como propósito
impedir la transmisión del virus un
mosquito que además de transmitir el
dengue también transmite el cica el
chikungunya y la fiebre amarilla en
indonesia donde se implementó la
bacteria se anunció en junio que los
casos locales de dengue han reducido en
un 77 por ciento una esperanza para
luchar contra esta enfermedad que
infecta cada año a más de 50 millones de
personas en el mundo tienen esa
antrópica indiana como país tropical de
indonesia cuenta con varias zonas donde
viven que se volvió un problema
permanente
después llegó el cob y entonces es una
doble condena para los habitantes de
esta región
estas dos enfermedades pueden ser
mortales se aumentos a más ama fatal
lo que preocupa más a los expertos es el
crecimiento de casos entre los niños más
vulnerables frente al virus según el
reciente índice de riesgo climático de
los niños de unicef 115 millones de
niños están expuestos a la enfermedad
les cuento brevemente otras noticias
destacadas a lo largo de esta semana y
van a ver que las tres noticias están
entrelazadas entre sí colombia extendió
la emergencia sanitaria por kobe 19
hasta noviembre tiempo en el que este
país continuará con todas las reglas y
también las restricciones instauradas
debido a la situación epidemiológica que
está viviendo pero también extendió
hasta el 5 de septiembre las medidas
restrictivas contra el jove 19 es decir
en este país van a mantener el toque de
queda a nivel moderado y alto de lunes a
viernes y su duración va a depender de
la situación que está presentando cada
una de las provincias a lo largo y ancho
del territorio peruano y terminamos en
bolivia en este país también extendieron
los controles de circulación de viajes
internacionales y de medidas de
vigilancia vigentes hasta el 31 de
diciembre de este año esto como una de
las tantas medidas que está adoptando el
gobierno de bolivia
a mantenerse al frente de la situación
esto previendo una posible cuarta ola de
contagio por la variante delta en la
entrada del verano austral es decir en
los últimos meses del año
vamos a cambiar de tema los territorios
franceses de ultramar también están
luchando contra el kobe y 19 por
supuesto el planeta entero lo está
haciendo son particularmente complejos
los casos de guadalupe y de martinica
debido a la gran cantidad de casos que
se están presentando allí veamos algunas
de las cifras comenzamos en el extremo
norte en canadá allí el territorio o la
colectividad francesa de sant pierre y
miquelón sólo han reportado 30 casos en
todo un año y medio de emergencia
sanitaria y hasta ahora no tienen ningún
muerto pasamos ahora hasta la región del
caribe hay y martinica cuenta con más de
34 mil 700 casos y ya 200 personas han
perdido la vida en guadalupe más de 37
mil 900 casos han sido contabilizados y
400 personas han fallecido de otra parte
en san martín san martín el lado francés
recordemos que esta es una isla
compartida la otra mitad pertenece a los
países bajos allí contabilizan más de
3200 casos y 42 personas han fallecido y
finalizamos en sal barthélemy o san
bartolomé con el 1500 y solamente dos
personas han fallecido
les mencionaba que la situación es
particularmente compleja en la isla de
martinica en donde el contagio de
coronavirus no da tregua a las
autoridades de esta isla el
confinamiento y el toque de queda
vigente desde el pasado 30 de julio ya
fue extendido por tres semanas más es
decir hasta mediados de septiembre
mientras avanza también la vacunación el
inicio de las clases presenciales que
estaba previsto para ahora para el mes
de septiembre ya fue postergado y van a
regresar a las aulas virtuales para
poder proteger a los menores de la
variante delta
y ahora demos un vistazo a otras
noticias relacionadas con el hobby 19
destacadas en redes y comenzamos con
esta publicación israel inició una
campaña de test serológicos para los
menores de más de 3 años para determinar
si pueden desarrollar anticuerpos contra
el jove 19 a pesar de no estar vacunados
una publicación de france 24 punto com
israel le está haciendo frente
precisamente a una ola de contagio por
la variante delta pese a ser líder en
vacunación a nivel mundial
el siguiente tema la insinuación china
de que la pandemia comenzó en eeuu fue
completamente rechazada por la o ms en
este texto china pidió o en este
contexto mejor pidió a la o ms que
investigara varios laboratorios de eeuu
en su visita a wuhan lado ms planteó
cuatro hipótesis para el origen del cob
y 19 ninguna de estas planteaba que
podía haber iniciado en eeuu la más
probable es la transmisión de este virus
de un animal al humano y finalizamos con
esta noticia la ope es e impulsa la
transferencia de tecnología de vacunas a
américa latina este organismo
continental indicó que trabaja en la
transferencia de tecnología de las
vacunas de adn mensajero a nuestra
región para que varios países puedan
asociarse y fabricar en conjunto dosis
que protejan a millones de personas en
nuestra región y así no depender de los
suministros del exterior solamente 30
empresas han expresado su interés para
participar en este proyecto
y con esto llegamos al final de este
resumen aquí en kobe 19 la semana en
américa nos vemos la próxima semana
mientras tanto sigan cuidándose del cobi
19 usando tapabocas lavándose las manos
desinfectando se y por supuesto abriendo
france24 siga con nosotros
[Música]